You are listening to radiolab radio from
W. N. Y. S. T. E. Yup. Hi,
I'm Robert Krulwich. I'm Molly
Webster. This is Radiolab and today
we've got breaking news.
Robert Krulwich on Rick break.
This is something we've never
done before. Never done before.
What does anybody know about this yet?
Well, it is a new bit of research.
It's being published today. We've
known about it for the last few months,
but we haven't been able to talk about
it until now. What's this thing about?
Oh, this is a discovery
about Alzheimer's disease,
which I think at this point is something
that affects basically every family
affected my family. Yeah.
And this is a discovery
that is not a cure,
but it's basically about
looking at the brain,
which is one of the most complicated
things in the universe, I think.
And poking at it in this super simple way
and getting this bizarre result that's
pretty, pretty bizarre.
Hello? Hello? Hello.
Hi Molly. Hi. How are you?
All right. So last May,
I was talking to some folks over at the
brain institute at MIT and while I was
on the phone with them,
they started telling me about some
research that hadn't been published yet.
So it was all very hush.
Hush is pretty cool though.
We ended up deciding to sign
a nondisclosure agreement
and it was based on the
work of this woman. Leeway
tie the way. Tie, tie,
tie tie a,
I'm a professor and the director of the
Pico Institute for learning a memory at
MIT. Holy Crap. You're a director.
How do you have time to do? Oh,
that's a good question. She is was
like a bad ass is what she is about.
This is a piece of work. Um, I'm
very proud of and very excited about.
Okay, cool. So let me, let me begin. Okay,
so he's Dory Culley people work
on Alzheimer's, really focused.
So I would say generally when you talk
to researchers about Alzheimer's disease,
they either focus on
individual genetic factors,
the genetics of the disease,
so the genes that predispose you maybe
to Alzheimer's or the brain chemistry and
how Alzheimer's affects
the chemicals in the brain.
Molay killer pathological features
that in my conversation with leeway,
she was talking about something
totally different. We, we,
we sort of look at it
from a different angle.
Her work all centers around
something called the gamma frequency
gamma and what is gay? I'm like,
it feels like something
from Battlestar Galactica,
so I don't think it's that you could
think of it as a particular beat in your
brain, in the brain, which
means let things likely.
Well,
just to oversimplify one of the most
complicated things in the known universe.
Okay, please do. You've got your
brain. It's full of neurons,
which are a certain type of brain cell.
We have billions of neurons in the brain.
They have these long tentacles that are
reaching out towards other neurons and
for the brain to function,
neurons have to communicate with
each other to process inflammation.
And the way they do
that is they fire. Yes,
an electrical signal.
We'll go through them and it'll like zap
another neuron and it'll turn it on and
then in a like an electrical signal,
we'll go through it and then it'll zap
another neuron and it'll turn it on.
But the cool thing is is that when your
brain is doing things like making you
move or write a poem or
think great thoughts,
groups of neurons fire in
sync all together on the
same beat and there's a bunch
of different beats that happen in
the brain. Some of them are slow,
like one beat per second and
that's when you're sleeping.
If you're beating around
10 beats per second,
like maybe you're sitting next to a
campfire in an Adirondack chair or on like
the totally other end of the spectrum,
like some neurons fire at 600 beats
per second or do they do that?
I have no idea what all this is going
on. In your head simultaneously. Yeah,
yeah. No,
that's the cool thing is that when
all of these beats in your brain come
together,
that's when you're able to process the
world and understand it as it exists as
human beings.
[inaudible]
Huh? But getting back to our story,
when your brain is doing something
really tricky that requires super focused
tension, working memory and so on,
do like trying to find your way
home from the subway station.
Or if you're in a new city,
you know, navigate around it.
There's a certain beat, it
sort of rises above them all.
And that is the so called gamma frequency.
This range between 30 beats per second
all the way up to a hundred beats per
second. And this gamma
frequency has been, uh,
considered to be very important for
the higher order cognitive function.
And the interesting thing is that
when you look at an Alzheimer's brain,
what you see is there's actually less
gamma happening or people say like the
power of Gamma is reduced.
Now all the neurons can be recruited
to oscillate at the gamma frequency.
It's still there. It's just quieter. It's
like you turn the volume down. Right.
All right, so just to briefly sum up here,
what we've got is a rhythm
which we call gamma,
which is used when we have complicated
or higher thoughts in the brain,
which when you got Alzheimer's
kind of get saggy retired.
Yeah, totally. And of course,
obviously in an Alzheimer's brain there's
a lot going on and this is just one of
the things, right? You've got the
plaques that build up around the neurons,
this stuff that ducks up your brain and
makes it hard to think. Yeah, totally.
It's like cobwebs in the brain and then
the connections between neurons gets all
muddied and immune cells get
messed up. But leeway tie was like,
forget all that. What would happen
if I just bring the gamma back? Yeah.
We decided to just manipulate
gamma oscillations.
And how do you, how do you do that?
Well, hello. Hello? Hello? Hello? Hello?
Hello? Hello. Hello Technology.
Hi, this is Molly. Hi. Hi. Hi.
Technology you can find at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology.
And actually I went and took a train
up to Boston to MIT not too long ago,
walking in, did a big hour institute.
It's a big shiny glass building. Why
eventually leeway tie came striding
into her office to meet me.
And my understanding is that you want
to see some of the experimental setup.
And so we way led me down
the hall to this tiny room.
The mice just entered the room,
brought in these adorable little mice.
Oh my gosh. They're like little
black and soft and furry. Yeah.
Their ears are tagged with a little
metal tag on that. Yeah. Okay. So,
so here's what they did. They get some
ice. We started off with a mouse model,
not the mice. I actually
got all excited over,
but my set at an early stage of
Alzheimer's disease was my depo.
Notable defects.
And do they have the gunky plaque
stuff in them yet or is that later? No,
but they do have elevated levels
of um, open amyloid peptides,
which is this protein
that forms the plaques.
So it's like basically preplan gunk.
But the important thing to leeway tie
in our team is that they have less gamma
going on in their brains. If you remember,
the whole plan here is to
bring the gamma back. Yes.
So to do that,
they get what might be the world's
tiniest drill and they drill a small hole
into the skull of the mouse and then they
take a really thin fiber optic cable.
They slide it through
the hole into the brain,
and then they get this laser of blue
light to flicker at 40 beats per second.
Yeah, Ma frequency. And they turn
that on and the light travels
down the fiber optic cable
deep down into the brain,
to this group of cells that
they've modified in the
hippocampus to be sensitive
to light. So when this
pulsing light hit the cells,
they actually began to fire at 40
beats per second at gamma frequency.
And they would keep these cells
firing a gamma for one hour,
firing and firing and firing
and firing and firing. And then
after one hour they turn off the light.
And then eventually they started looking
at the brains of these mice trying to
figure out if anything was different after
the light flashed and they see to our
much surprise or not
expecting this at all,
we found after they shot this
pulsing light into the brain,
there was suddenly nearly half as
much of that soon to be nasty plaque,
gunk stuff that was filling up their
hippocampus. [inaudible] half the, yeah.
Yes. Half of the stuff
was just swept away. Yes.
40 to 50% reduction of Beta amyloid.
That just seems crazy.
This is crazy. I mean,
we were just so surprised.
They know why the, yeah. Yeah,
so turned out to the pulsing light somehow
triggered the brain's cleanup crew,
microglia. These cells in the
brain that are called Microglia,
you can say they're the janitors of
the brain, and in a normal brain,
these janitor cells
usually gobble up the gunk.
But in Alzheimer's disease it's
known that Michael [inaudible],
they don't sort of
function normally anymore.
It's like these janitors just sort
of stop cleaning up and go on strike.
There we go. Okay, cool. Okay. So we're
looking at a screen that's now flat.
It's not, not when I was at MIT,
one of Leeways Grad students,
my name is Anthony March row.
Second Year was showing me side by side
comparisons of these mice brains on the
screen. Can you guess what that is?
Which part? The green things. Microglia.
And you see after one hour
of gamma. Wow. So that, yeah,
that the Michael [inaudible] the
cell seems a lot bigger clearly.
See these round bodies. Yeah.
And also the bally sims
will have more amyloid. Oh,
like they're doing more eating. Yes.
They go back to eat more amyloid again.
It's like somehow making the neurons fire
turned on the sanitation system in the
brain. But the most wild results, wait,
there's more wild, oh my God,
you gotta hear this because
what I'm about to tell you,
you may say no, I don't believe
it. It's science fiction. Okay. So,
so one of the things leeway and her
team were starting to think was that
drilling and fiber optic
cable is very invasive. Right.
You'd never be able to do that on a
human. Exactly. So we started to say,
well,
what if we can get the light into
the brain in a different way?
Like maybe we could go through the eyes
towing the hole in your head would be
your eyes instead of a whole. Yes.
So leeway and her team created what I
like to think of as the flicker room.
This is the room, this is the
room, and then it turns out,
I learned upon my visit, it is just a
storage closet. You know you have a,
what is this? Just like a plastic
table. Very DIY. Yeah, it's a,
it's a plastic table
you can buy at target.
There were some plastic shoe box size
containers lined up on the table for the
mice.
And then see the strip around the edge
of the table physically surrounding all
the pages are duck tape
strips of led lights.
And the reason why we use LEDs
is because a regular light bulb,
it can't flash fast enough.
And so the idea is what if we just put
the mice in this room and just let the
light flicker at 40 beats per second.
So you want to show Molly
like attorneys on, yeah,
and so we turn off the overhead light in
the room, so it's very black and white
then. Oh Wow.
The room was now glowing with
this white led light. Okay.
So the light is turning on and off 40
times a second. It's so there's, you know,
you don't see anything going like on or
off. It just looks like something's on.
But it kind of feels like
my eye is twitching and so
it's blurring the blurring
the light a little just on the
edges though, on the edges.
And do they put mice in this room for
an hour and just let them kind of bays
bathe in this, in this
glow. And guess what?
What we look at the amyloid Beta levels
in the visual cortex and we found there
is a 50% reduction,
50% 50% of the doctors shining
light in their eyeballs.
Yes they did.
They didn't do any drilling or
anything? No, they didn't drill.
They didn't tweak the mouse's brain
cells to be sensitive to light.
This is just the room with occasional
LEDs flashing at a particular frequency
for an hour. Now do you see,
are you going to tell me?
I don't believe it is science fiction.
And they follow this study up with another
study which was done in the same way.
So at the same flicker room light through
the eyeballs and only this time they
put the mice in there for one hour a day
for seven days and they took mice that
had full blown Alzheimer's. So
this is like cognitive decline.
They're forgetting things and they've
got hardened plaques in their brain and
they see the same thing. Nearly
half of the stuff was cleared away.
Half.
It's just flickering light in
front of the mice. That's the shot.
I mean that's the shocking thing.
The thing I didn't understand after
talking to you about your study was I was
like, why hasn't everyone done this
before? Like why didn't everyone go?
We should just shine light
through eyes. See? Well you know,
that's really the most unexpected
and exciting aspect of our study,
which is some sin this simple. Yet.
You know it has never been done before.
You know that. One of the things,
one of the caveats here is that if you
don't do the flicker light room every 24
hours,
the level of gunk in the brain starts
going back up again and so now they're
trying to figure out how they
can keep those levels down.
Maybe even for good if the mouse no
longer has quite as much junk in its head.
Does that mean that it can remember
things that happened to it?
Yeah. Yeah. That is their big next
research. That's what they are.
They don't know that's what they're
to. That is now the next step,
but nobody really understands how
plaques and the gunk buildup in the brain
relates to memory and cognition and the
dogma in the field is that when you have
Alzheimer's,
you can't form new memories
and once you lose a memory,
it's gone for good.
But there is another group at MIT that
is actually sort of challenging that
assumption that you can never get a memory
back because the patient could never
tell us. We all assumed the information
had to be gone. Oh really? Yeah,
and we'll get to them, but
first we have to go to a break.
This is Kevin Murray from
Fort Collins, Colorado.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Sofi,
a new kind of finance company.
Did you know that student loan refinancing
is a great way to accomplish more
with less student debt. If you worked
hard to get the career you want,
Sophie is here to offer savings.
Sophie refinances student loans to save
its members $316 a month on average.
Learn more at [inaudible] dot com terms
and conditions apply@sofi.com slash.
Legal
I'm Robert Krulwich. I'm Molly Webster.
Yes, he is radio lab and we're back.
And just before the break you said that
there may be a way to bring a memory
back from the Alzheimer's.
Does pull the memory back into
back into place. Yeah. Why?
Why are we so quick to jump
to the conclusion that the
information was somehow
completely gone? And the person
who said that to me is this guy,
I'm Dheeraj Roy,
I'm a fourth year graduate student in
the Sumo Tonegawa lab over at the town of
gala lab. They were thinking,
what if we could figure out exactly where
the memory should be in the brain and
just give that spot a
little bit of juice, right?
So they took some mice that were just
starting to lose their ability to remember
things and they thought, okay,
let's try to give them a memory.
We put them in a box that
has a particular smell,
some sort of lighting and
some texture on their feet.
A little mouse carpet or that's exactly
what it is. Yeah. Okay. My son cockpits.
Got It.
The point is the box looks and feels
and smells different than any other box
they would hang out in. And then you'd
give them a light electrical shock.
And the mice, they just
freeze. They don't move at all,
which is a sign that they're
afraid, the hate the box
[inaudible]
and for the rest of the afternoon, which
is a very long time and mouse time,
they go on hating the box,
which means with the carpet
and the light and the smell,
if you put it back in there, it'll
freeze because it remembers the shot.
Yes. But a day or a week later,
which when the same mice were
put back into the same box,
instead of being scared of the box,
they would just continue
investigating as if nothing happened.
They could not remember.
So Dheeraj and his team did leeway,
did they got some modified mice and then
they put a little hole in their head.
They slid in a fiber optic
cable, they [inaudible]
shine some light to trigger the
neurons if they think hold this memory.
And they were a fear section
near the fear section.
So leading on the path to the fear
section. So we do this and then
put them back into the box,
the box with a particular lighting
and smell and carpet and ask,
is there any change in their
behavior? Will they act afraid again?
Do they show any more memory?
And they did wait. Shut up. They actually
were scared of the box again. Exactly.
They showed recovered memory.
Wow. Oh, so that's like Bam.
That memory is in there.
Exactly. [inaudible] behaviors back
and you can dig up the memory by
shining light in the right place.
Yeah.
I was always under the impression that
the memories were totally lost. Right.
So I think that's not just you. I think
that's essentially the entire field,
what you described just because,
and that's good because the
patient could never tell us.
We all assume that the
information had to be gone. Huh.
So one of the things to say is that
Dheeraj did tell me that, you know,
all of the experiments they did are
in mice that have early Alzheimer's.
Uh, the thought is though is that once
you get to the late stage of the disease,
there's enough damage in the brain that
you really wouldn't be able to get those
memories back.
That might be right that a
memory lost is just lost.
But you know, when you, when you
have someone in your house and you,
um, and you live with this
disease day in and day out,
the disease just goes its own way and
it can puzzle you or frighten you or
suddenly declare something new that
you didn't expect. So for example,
my dad had it for about
nine, 10 years. Uh,
it was a slow, active disappearing
that he did where, I mean,
the last time my father came
to was so far into the disease,
he hadn't spoken for a year and a half.
He was sitting at the table for the
Passover Seder and there's a song that you
sing and it goes, died
a new die, die. Ain't no
[inaudible]. So it's just a
chorus. And from out of nowhere,
this being at the end of the table,
who I knew was my father,
who hadn't spoken in a year and a half
or two and had not spoken coherently for
three,
suddenly flew into the song
[inaudible]
and sang the song full
throated Lee at the table.
[inaudible]
the reappearance of some just figment
of himself.
[inaudible]
and it was, it was both horrifying
and extraordinary. Both,
you know. Yeah.
I think that's the fact that maybe
some information still the persists.
Hopefully someday we get kind of, maybe
there's something we could do. Um,
but yeah,
[inaudible] in my mind at the moment,
as long as we can figure out how to
reboot the pathway to retrieve the memory,
then I think there is hope.
This is the way tie again,
but you know, I,
I personally seeing the most important
question is whether humans respond
similarly. I mean,
keep in mind that both Daraja
study and leeway ties are in mice,
not humans. Right. So I do have a
thought that like, why, like, um,
is there a reason that a human neuron
might react differently than a mouse?
The thing is as thing, especially,
you know, in Alzheimer's feel, I mean,
people got burned a lot.
Yeah. Just, you know,
there's like a 99.6% failure rate in
moving something that seemed to work in
mice to humans in Alzheimer's. Yeah. Yeah.
That was a study that came out in
2012. That's a horrible number.
So I just gotta be
really conservative here.
Dial it back. I'll dial it back. You
know, all we have in mice, the just,
just so exciting and so
unexpected, so much fun.
Um, but you know,
I'm gonna keep my mind open
when it comes to humans.
The plan is,
is that we're going to find out because
they're going straight to humans. Oh.
So can do human trials. Well, they
want to, so yeah, I guess we'll see.
This is the glorious part of
all this. This organ of ours,
the brain is so crazily
complicated with like whatever,
100 trillion connections or whatever
it is. There's so much chance.
There's gonna be a lot of
surprise. Yeah. It's like almost,
even if it doesn't lead to any,
uh, treatment in humans or, um,
something super concrete. It's like,
we know this little secret
about the brain now,
and there's something that
feels like beautiful in that.
Yeah. I'm actually, I'm setting
this up for my Christmas tree.
Are you really? Yes. Oh wait,
I just bought the new
led lights and they can,
they can flick her a different
color with different colors.
Each individual bulb can travel through
colors, but while they're doing that,
they're going to be
flickering at 40. Well,
you're going to have a very
therapeutic Christmas in the,
in the leeway tie household. This
is the tree in your home. Oh,
yes. Yes. Are you using, I want to
have an eggnog next to that tree.
Okay. Thank you, Molly, for what?
A remarkable story that was. Um,
you're welcome. It was also produced
by Eddie Mcewen, Matt Kielty,
Molly Webster, again with help from
Simon Adler and special thanks to
Sumu Tonegawa at MIT, and thank
you all for listening. Bye.